well we're all very excited to have you
here but I must warn you the Gaul pact
has eyes everywhere be careful what you
say and let your gain do the talking
have no doubt I'm as healthy as ever and
I shoot threes now there's no reason we
can't form a super team here it is you
who is that it something you know Mario
Chalmers we used to play together in
Miami okay here we go
hello real now you're on the Bulls now
oh that's so weird we was on a super
team together the big four remember
those days Dwayne no but I can't blame
you for leaving really Twilight of your
career bad knees bad shoulders maybe you
can scrape together one last player on
with sorry what's your nice Jimmy Butler
oh you do look a lot like Michael Jordan
well it's all very exciting ma we must
be going now I'm afraid oh all right
well if you need to pour God or whatever
just send me a raven yes we are Brando
oh well you never know with him he's a
bit you'll definitely need a veteran
backup now we have plenty of depth but
we'll keep you in mind could you know we
could for your super team again by Rio
you can yell at me all you like
I don't mind all right well I guess I'll
head to Cleveland
[Music]
- yuxun come in come in I came to say
hello and welcome you to use them
ah why thank you and you must be the no
scouting apprentice I've been expecting
you
I am your starting shooting guard James
Harden all realm shooting guard James
James you sir when wanna me please haha
James Harlan the point guard will give
shooting I've been studying your game
it's marvelous brilliant really
oh that's very kind of you to say so you
have a lot of books I see this whole
shelf is inbound place is baseline
sideline I also keep ISO clays in there
somewhere for no good reason really
and this shelf here all books on the art
of the top over there this tempo click
ticking rolls you name it feel free to
borrow them as you click away I bet you
need whole new library just for all
defensive plays defense like you know
and the team has the ball and it should
- you know school um oh no no no no none
of that here it's a waste of energy
that's no fun I say half the defense
sample the asset
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]